l'interdiction par lé nos langues c'est
un génocide
sue ellen siens à l'intérieur de l'être
humain s'est pas gêné
génocide c'est une chanson coup de poing
qui dénonce avec force les traitements
subis par les premières nations du
canada depuis des siècles samia lie
creed dans la foulée de la mort de joyce
et chaque coin c'est autochtone qu'il
était dernier a été abreuvé d'insultés
racistes par le personnel soignant de
l'hôpital de joliette où elle est
décédée je me suis écoute c'est beaucoup
plus que du racisme systémique
on parle d'un jeune et c'est pour éviter
passé par plusieurs chemins pour
[Musique]
génocide et la seule chanson en français
de ce cinquième album d autres sont en
algonquin
la gonfle et se porte bien au rap comme
les nous sommes pour bien la chanson je
veux dire c'est vraiment une langue qui
est quand même assez sec assez direct et
c'est une traduction souvent c'est très
imagé c'est pas une traduction littérale
c'est avec sa grand-mère que samia a
pris l'algonquin né dans une réserve
d'abitibi témiscamingue dans le nord du
québec d'une mère algonquine et d'un
père québécois sam yann ne parlait que
français sa grand mère a été dans les
pensionnats autochtones ces
établissements religieux mis en place
par les autorités canadiennes au xxème
siècle pour assimiler les enfants
autochtones et leur faire perdre leur
culture
un ancien pensionnaire témoigne
d'ailleurs dans un clip de sagnol il
était à kamloops ce pensionnat où on a
retrouvé cet été plus de 2 100
dépouilles d'enfants moi en ce moment ce
que je trouve difficile c'est le message
que le canada envoie à l'échelle
internationale
c'est comme si on disait
génocide chez nous il est légal il est
impuni et au lieu de dénoncer les
agresseurs on va les protéger c'est
vraiment ce que je trouve le plus
difficile à accepter en ce moment
cette colère que ressent l'artiste de 38
ans il la canalise pour qu'elle s'ouvre
sur le dialogue oui je peux être en
colère que je peux je peux l'exprimer et
je vais l'exprimer cette façon là mais
pour moi j'ai toujours essayé de
le portugal est en pleine phase si je
dire de pau est agressif ou ne pas être
violent avec la musique donc le message
se veut toujours positif j'essaie
toujours de trouver une façon de trouver
une solution et cette solution elle
passe par une réconciliation entre
blancs et autochtones j'ai beaucoup de
misère à croire que que que nos
politiciens essaient de deux de nous
vendre une réconciliation je mentionne
aussi un peu solide et puis je pense que
socialement on est on est en avance
là-dessus
[Musique]
cette réconciliation ça miaule incarne
également en étant un pont entre les
cultures blanche et autochtone de part
son métissage et il se réjouit de la
place grandissante des artistes
autochtones sur la scène culturelle
québécoise il vient d'ailleurs de fonder
sa maison de production pour offrir un
tremplin aux jeunes artistes autochtones
ou non et pour se libérer des diktats de
l'industrie de la musique et pouvoir
faire les choses à sa façon et c'est
catherine françois radio canada montréal